four o'clock or so Monday morning
Los Angeles ready rock and roll was a
way for the week family time and feel
super recharged and ready to go super
excited about this week great day in LA
today action-packed a couple days of New
York got a quick trip to Dallas and back
same day on Thursday and Friday
similarly morning important meetings and
then I'm heading out for Fantasy
Baseball Draft weekend one of my
favorite weekend's of the year so it's
gonna be a great great great great hotel
new all my second favorite numbers by
the way that's my favorite number but
that's how many days I'd like to go hard
mentally at least McIlwain um mom
doesn't got a graduate coming round
actually Michael Knight like a vision
for what I see with clarity hustle my my
name is Gary Thomas I've been telling
you
accountability I'll triple a given a
pedigree to mean an especial necessity
including the word challenger nerd the
move of furniture seven
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much
rollin in la go into another meeting
just spent two hours at CIA four or five
different meanings ran into grand
kessman michael Kiva's some of the old
homies I signed with back in 2007 get to
see a preview of planet of the apps
which was incredible it's going to be
good
spokes Peter Jacobsen my speaking world
met some new characters around voice
overs podcast and stuff of that nature
feeling pretty good and really excited
and so I'm a very productive day so far
in LA did a bigger sports meeting
earlier today met with a kind of a
creative team here in LA Juliet fun to
see her had a lovely meeting with a
former employee strategizing long term
and just an awfully productive three or
four hours mainly off the record sorry
Dirac wait like a sad d-roc face
actually I'm going to come and do this
d-roc it's been very off the record so
far today in LA make it make the sad
dear I face the Western dollars can you
hey I told me jqi that was good
how about you won't be able to use any
of this well you're putting music over
it you know how to edit your wedding
right they're taking wet it right tell
me let it rain down down down mornin
everybody change they can tape it change
it so my last night did I make this few
ropes up early today with a view nice
and calm for a moment time of the time
didn't pass tilden you'll just fell I
sleep
get back to the dreams that I had my
head so if you saw here today with a
wake up but I woke up ROK's it said that
a rule seems me like J also do a say no
say no say no more to heart to be live
been working to pay ready who works more
that's what's good about me right and I
don't know I said I don't know when I
know I [ __ ] tell you I know I imagine
when audacity was all I could use to
meet your friends I had are still here
and they keep on telling me is how a
year
go sit - yes is 2012 still not just
saying oh you're right
I mean this second no straining
second-round picks are going to change
everything
it's a monster monster change like
there's one player that I'm willing to
spend all my I don't know that it's
really good I'm really enjoying how its
evolving you know I can't even imagine
that first four seconds of your brain
when you specific G grass was really
good that was so funny luscious I'm so
pumped print thank you we have not hung
out a Friday afternoon to Sunday night
in 100 years
[Music]
I'm on the right Road become a laughing
my god I'm so dirty and everything that
I got that I saw you watch it's only one
time uh name are you coming to the draft
yeah you're the core of the team right
nobody can never not know who you are
because I saw Sydney and I'm thinking of
my boy no real talk I'm singing on like
it's so familiar right oh my one more
yeah yeah down the other have a good
night you Brian thank you appreciate it
my man
stay well
it up like this girl man Harrison your
iPhone hey man how are you I'm good
thanks yeah real pleasure hey nice to
meet you oh that what kind of Rick and
Morty one in the spaceship over there
yep and so I was like wow this is really
amazing and I said how much would it
cost in supplies for you to paint 20 of
them to me he said 300 so I gave him a
gram and said go to town and I said once
you get it back to me I'll do a vlog
then I'm creeping up on a million
subscribers on YouTube so that I'll do a
vlog enough tweeted and on Instagram it
and you really get it animal to me Tomic
I reflected that's [ __ ] awesome
that's you ever shoot pool I used to
back in the day why are you really good
no he's really good yeah yeah I'll like
I'm crashing yeah
when you stand on a finally meet again
America stupid aka the greatest moments
of our lives
I thought you told me took the music
deal for the tour not the stupid [ __ ]
I'm just kidding I'll get it Oh get in
there oh I think I think everybody
actually does have the [ __ ] yes I know
you did you like a site set up perfectly
we'll be editing that poem okay ours
rarely to just talked to their fans on
Twitter or you know hold content select
all different kinds of things you know
just like roots on [ __ ] to interact a
fan where most people will then get to a
level where they start with the fan
getting overly like welcome them down
yeah so screen your action let me go
like it doesn't matter how much Michael
Jackson wanted it to you just going out
[Music]
[Music]
it was interesting you got to pick and
choose your battles right but I'm like I
think logics exactly right like I'm
always going to sleep in the bed that I
make yeah that's what he just said
that's exactly right like you can't be
like trying to like build brand make
stuff happen
and have all the good stuff that comes
along with it and then cry if somebody
like bothers you when you're eating
spaghetti you can do whatever you want
but that's just I'm in full agreement
with that you know I usually the drive
is white Impala investing i'ma get a pen
I'm gonna pull the [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
have my dream dress my dream house in my
dream car let me know six everything I
want to go oh
[Music]
that hurt love another seat yeah Ruth
you sir you were super hearts are quant
yes like as a kid you got real good at
it I only learned this like a year and a
half ago and well you're good now
okay yeah I like it hahaha
you got really good oh god okay there's
people there's so what you watch on
YouTube video to be honest it's
unbelievable how that's the answer to
every like that's it like how to go
online financially secure so do you ever
just go like I've you ever done a song
just from the top of the head or do you
write I write everything about yeah I
believe that I mean don't get me wrong
I've gone in and sure there's like
certain song sometimes happen I just go
in and there's a vibe or something but
for the most part I could take my time
because I you know I want to be revered
as one of the greatest so I believe
that's your process yeah you know yeah
you should like it people need to know
their prop like for me when I speak I
only can do improv yeah well I can't
right yeah no I mean but that makes
sense like splinting it's like for
example like when I'm live speaking in
front of you almost a thousand people
it's like yeah I'm not just gonna like
what was I going to say like you know
it's moments and there's [ __ ] like I do
there's a super fun things that you can
do to just like react to what's going on
yeah you're going on or whatever the
case would be is just it's just funny
sense though when you think about the
right like the songs right like I mean I
don't know please God be 500 but like
it's not unlimited if you're gonna have
your songs yeah like that's gonna be
your life it's kind of cool I'm here
with an unbelievable talent that a
better dude we're about to do an
askgaryvee for the four of you that
don't know this is logic logic say
what's up dead people has a gun I'm
awkwardly waving to the camera now
that's good it was a good awesome yes
Jay so logic is an incredible artist for
the few that don't know we're about to
go into an askgaryvee you'll see the
minitor squeakers do the amount of
cursing no the amount of curse like I do
is Phenom
you'll be super super comfortable if you
want to curse school so we're about to
do this hope everybody's super well
great for you but you rock is here
you rock glad to be back on the grind
yeah no I'm not sad anymore I know you
got some good color by Mike Boyd you
ready hey hey hey all right let's do
this
all right got that my man take care
yourself that's a look gang dad's advice
you gave that dude that's okay logic
what what about you as an entrepreneur
as a kid so you were very artistic
you're clearly artistic and thoughtful
did you have a selling DNA where you
like going by blow pops and try to sell
them like the D on that machine to tell
you a story that I've never told anyone
else like here we go so where I come to
get close yeah it's not like when I grew
up you know saying I was like hella poor
I didn't have [ __ ] right you stolen Sol
[ __ ] no damn no because I think that's
okay notice I wouldn't step further i
logic yes you're good dude you're good
dude I love you we're good dude
now question of the day you get to ask
everybody the question of the day
there'll be thousands of comments in
Facebook and YouTube to this question
what's the question you want to put out
to the 13 14 15 year-olds and everybody
else in the world what would you like to
see them answer might be a good
opportunity to get a little bit of a
feedback loop yeah maybe some might be
able to get some insight on something
from the masses and that's it I didn't
know that I know that's why I rolled up
notice hiding give you that heads up
beforehand this awkward pause right now
is everything to me I'm going to rewind
and watch this part this is going to be
an amazing question I'm predicting the
greatest question asked by guests in the
history of the askgaryvee show
why do you think let's be good actually
so yeah I hope you guys like that hope
you had fun logic last parting gifts
thanks for being cool I don't go follow
me logic really let me guys talk to you
soon I didn't know well the only one is
that was good hungry logic for good kid
man it'll go kid look at this diesel
dude
monster respect the process is so real
respect your brand thank you my man
because of this because if they're
interested the process a deal this guys
[ __ ] a monster Oh Jordan yeah look at
her toes mystery huh let's see at stupa
do over the ground we put a gram are you
say my pleasure really I don't know call
me something here my pleasure my man
you guys haven't oh [ __ ] at this power I
don't know maybe it was just too obvious
you how to do something with it okay
alright guys so yeah early
transformation airport carry
[Music]
[Music]
la good trip logic your legend warp done
you guys are hustling - that's it
redeye NYC cool
[Music]